Katie do you think the media has learned
it's lessons from 2016 and will cover
the election differently in 2020 or is
Trump destined to suck up all the oxygen
again I would say definitely oxygen he
games the press I and and he's he is
that his is one skill he is such a good
marketer and such a good manipulator of
the message right I think also from the
very beginning I think we fell into a
particular kind of trap where we said we
don't want to normalize him so anything
he does it's you know outside the norm
we're gonna react too aggressively well
he loves that so he knows now that we're
gonna respond I sometimes think it what
if you just had a week it was it no
matter what you do we won't cover you
and just like he thinks all attention is
good attention but I think that that
media outlets have to make a concerted
effort not to fall into them you know
the problem is something called the most
popular list because the moment you have
a title that says Trump whatever it is
going to pop out Regis than your if I
write if write if I write a column about
the oppression of we Gers in western
China you're talking about a million
people in gulags but people aren't going
to care if it's Trump's latest bad tweet
it will pop and so some kind of
self-discipline is required by
journalists exactly what you said a week
of a Trump kind of / outrage on both
sides sells and that's why both sides
does it probably keep trying to do worse
and worse and worse things until he
finally gets that attention but I agree
it's hard every single day to figure out
what you do and don't respond to because
some of the things are really horrible
and you know if he's gonna firebend men
and his brother and interfere and in
Roger stones sentencing and I mean you
have to say something about it you can't
let that go but it's tough okay what do
you think about Trump's 20-21 budget it
is
horrible he is a liar he goes into the
State of the Union and says I'm not
touching your Medicare I'm not touching
your Social Security I'm gonna invest in
education and then he comes out with a
budget that cuts Medicare that's Social
Security money from the Pentagon from
for the wall which now by the way
remember when Mexico was gonna pay for
the wall definitely not paying for this
wall it is the American taxpayer his
fans have goldfish memory they really
did I hate to say it but you know a
goldfish they say they go around the
thing and they see the little palm tree
every time they go hey look a palm tree
like Mexico oh babe no I never said that
he's amazing the way he can pull that
off Brett were you surprised to see rush
limbaugh make derogatory remarks about
Pete buddhaya kissing his husband so
soon after receiving his Presidential
Medal of Freedom
no van do you share some congressional
Democrats concerns that a Bernie Sanders
ticket might impair their chances to
hold on to the house in 2020 that's a
part about Bernie Sanders we didn't
discuss is the down-down ticket
dragged perhaps some people I'm sure are
not going to run want to run with a
socialist at the top of the ticket yeah
it's hard it's hard to know what I do
know is that Bernie's particular brand
of socialism is probably better
described as grandparent in be right if
you're a young person like think about
your grandparents went to college for
like 4 bucks right you say I want that
right your grandparents they get sick
you know they got Medicare they want to
get doctor I want that like it's not the
socialism that we remember from the 70s
we're like you want to nationalize
everything is there you just right young
people want what their grandparents have
I wish you would just call it that but
here's what I don't understand about
about birdie I mean one of the one of
the themes that he and his supporters
make is we don't want Venezuela we want
Denmark and the Danes will tell you were
you know a highly socialized economy but
we're also very vigorously capitalist
economy so what part of capitalism does
Bernie like and why doesn't he ever talk
about it
well because I think he's trying to
write some of the things that have
happened over the last thirty years
where we have really seen this economy
go towards the biggest corporations and
the wealthiest so he has to call that
out right we gotta but he can also say
we want a dynamic economy we want we
want world-class companies we want to be
leaders in various Astra's why doesn't
he say that but he's not taking on any
of those he doesn't not say them he's
talking about the root causes that's out
there you know when I talk about
Medicare for all I say well look I'm not
asking to buy my computer from the
government or my coffee from the
government I come from Seattle but I do
want my health insurance guaranteed and
paid for by the government and I think
that is a distinction that's really
important to make but you have to
understand how threatening he is because
you have been reading for quite a while
and you do not like Donald Trump you
think he is an existential threat blah
blah blah but your recent column said
but if it's Bernie I'm not gonna vote
for Trump I didn't say that I did not
say I in a vote for Trump I will vote
for a giraffe
[Applause]
either either he's so exist tential you
there's only two choices that's yeah I'm
gonna write in Mickey Mouse okay then I
mean I mean I mean look in terms of my
vote I live in New York of course Bernie
Sanders is gonna be the so you would
vote for him if it was Trump vs. Bernie
no I I don't want I don't want the
Democratic Party oh you're helping Trump
if you don't vote for Bernie to put the
country to a choice where people like me
will say these are two bad alternatives
all right and too many voters will say
you know what it's like the meatloaf
song when it comes to Bernie Sanders
like I will do anything for love but I
won't do that is Bernie Sanders for most
Americans I don't I don't know that
that's true I mean we we have gone the
same route of putting up somebody who is
much more moderate who placed
independent voters but you know a tiny
slice in the middle and and here we are
with Donald Trump I mean you got you
know Jim Messina saying in 2016 give me
I wake up every morning and I dropped to
my knees and pray God give me Donald
Trump that is the arrogance of the
Democratic Party sometimes to think that
everybody wanted to he wanted right Oh
Donald correct correct he wanted Donald
Trump to be there because he was sure
that Hillary Clinton would beat Donald
Trump so you know there are probably a
lot of people who are saying you put
some you know a Bloomberg some person up
there I'm not I I I don't know I
we never I'm not we never open for that
person so what's our job always
surprising right would you like to
Bernie to pick us as VP oh I don't know
I haven't gotten there yet we got to win
BP is yeah Stacey Abrams
is definitely the B her phone is
probably bringing over everybody you see
every
yes stacy is amazing she's a dear friend
and they need to and she's a fabulous
politician and you know she I think she
would be a fantastic vice president and
hopefully president someday agree okay
thank you everybody
[Applause]
you